If it's your goal to build an effective next-generation animation pipeline, my first suggestion is to look at Unreal Engine for its ability to be an open platform.
Unreal provides access to its entire source code. It possesses an extensive C++ API with support for many third-party extensions, and Epic remains committed to open standards so you can future-proof your data as you see fit.
This ability to customize Unreal sets it apart from other applications. In addition to its entire source code, access to third-party libraries is happening every day.
Plus, if you aren't as skilled with coding as you'd like to be, artists can leverage a friendly visual scripting solution known as Blueprints to create advanced behaviors and interactions.
There's also a Python scripting system to help automate tasks.
This results in Unreal being a comprehensive toolset. It's designed to provide an effective solution for all departments so teams can come together under a single production hub.
Whether it's traditional production, virtual production, interactive or immersive, Unreal has a solution for the most complicated projects.
Let's take a look at some of the recent technology upgrades in UE5.
First off, we have Nanite, Unreal's virtualized geometry system which allows access to billions of triangles where poly budgets don't apply and normal maps are no longer necessary.
Lumen, a fully dynamic global illumination system, removes the need for light map baking and provides real-time lighting interaction.
Virtual textures are capable of leveraging 8K cinematic assets and spatialized audio is now able to create realistic sound fields for increased immersion.
The results speak for themselves with animation companies like RealFX and Braun Animation producing entire episodic productions within the engine.
Epic has also produced its own example of what can be accomplished with Unreal Engine, Sequencer and its animation toolset. Check out the Mercat short film example for more.